Україна має бути в НАТО якомога швидше і
без процедури плану дій щодо членства
про це останнім часом багато говорили
західні експерти дипломати та військові
перед самітом Альянсу який має відбутися
11-12 липня у Вільнюсі та чи запросять
там Україну в НАТО
остаточно рішення досі немає
країни-члена Альянсу намагаються
подолати розбіжності
парадоксальна ситуація є українська
армія Яка найбільш загартована у боях і
найбільш готова відповідати на загрози
такі як Росія
не запросити країну яка найбільше готова
відбивати загрози це парадокс з іншого
боку в основі НАТО є механізм
політичного консенсусу подолати який
дуже важко НАТО продовжуватиме
підтримувати Україну надавати зброю
війна Росії проти України стала сигналом
Я особисто вважаю що він вочевидь був
недостатньо сильним аби всі остаточно
прокинулися в Європі деяких країни
подвоїли інвестиції в оборону деякі лише
трохи усвідомлення реальної небезпеки
особливо у західних столицях Європи ще
поки немає не знаю що має статися щоб
усі почали приводити НАТО у стан в якому
він був Україна надала сенс НАТО
на думку експертів є декілька варіантів
розвитку подій із запрошенням України в
НАТО зокрема це прискорений шлях після
припинення війни без жодних умов або
зумови успішної боротьби з корупцією
проведенням судової реформи та інших
реформ в країні може бути і традиційний
птч план дій щодо членства з усім
спектром консультації і допомоги на
шляху до вступу в НАТО ще один варіант
меморандум що Україна неодмінно стане
членом Альянсу і зазначенням конкретної
дати до якої це має статися
водночас через скупчення на які працював
спецпомічником президента США Барака
Обами коли почалася війна на Донбасі
радить Києву На даному етапі менше
перейматися питанням членства в НАТО Та
чи буде найближчим часом пропозиція про
вступ натомість більше сконцентруватися
на плані конкретної військової допомоги
в Україні
більша частина конкретного прогресу
досягнутого на саміті стосуватиметься
отримання Україною необхідною військовою
допомогою та обговорення зокремами
державами членами НАТО політичних
відносин і гарантій безпеки у середині
НАТО не має консенсусу щодо основного
питання членства І доки не буде Цього
консенсусу та згоди країн-членів НАТО
можливо 32 після того як Швеція
приєднається до Альянсу Вони не зможуть
взяти на себе конкретні зобов'язання з
надання запрошення Україні
і як наслідок Я думаю ми побачимо
надихаючі промови заохочувані слова але
нічого такого що могло б стати
залізобетонною гарантією щодо термінів
чи особливостей членства України в НАТО
у США та країнах західної Європи зокрема
Німеччини ретельно зважують ризики та
загрози ескалації з боку Росії Яка
називала розширення НАТО на Схід одним
із приводів війни з Україною натомість
країни Східної та Центральної Європи
виступають за конкретний механізм
залучення України в НАТО і нагадують що
політика стримування Росії провалилася і
не може бути довгострокового миру в
регіоні без вступу України в НАТО триває
дискусії щодо гарантії безпеки для
України з боку окремих потужних країн
наприклад ізраїльська модель коли США
зобов'язалися підтримувати Ізраїль зброю
та в інший спосіб чи може це стати
альтернативою повноцінним членству
України в НАТО
ми не розглядаємо альтернативу Ані на
рівні президента Ані на інших
ізраїльська модель звучить Непогано але
цього замало я знаю як Ізраїль досягнув
рівня безпеки і що вони для цього
зробили Не варто забувати про
ізраїльську ядерну силу Хай неофіційно
це відрізняється від ситуації в Україні
яка добровільно відмовилася від ядерної
зброї та її носіїв передавши це Росії це
була велика помилка але не України а США
Які думали що Росія піде демократичним
шляхом
якщо ми говоримо про Ізраїль то це
фінансова та військова підтримка Україна
отримує велику підтримку не лише від США
а й від європейських країн та країн не
членів НАТО Ізраїль в особливій ситуації
Ця країна менша ніж Україна я не думаю
що Україна Житиме під загрозою нападів
щодня ми продемонструємо що будь-які
напад у майбутньому спричинить негайну
відповідь
відверто кажучи я не хочу ізраїльську
модель але я хотів би для України угоди
з однією з країн які мають ядерну зброю
зі США британією чи Францією ці країни
надали їй Україні запевнені у безпеці
Будапештський меморандум Я вважаю що
ізраїльська модель для Ізраїлю Україна
матиме свою модель і я вважаю що ця
модель означатиме Україна в НАТО
[музика]
формальну заявку на вступ Україна подала
що у вересні 2022 року Київ неодноразово
заявляв що чекає від саміту у Вільнюсі
конкретних кроків одним з них стане
підвищення статусу створеної ще у 1997
році комісії Україна НАТО до рівня ради
перше засідання на рівні голів держав та
урядів має відбутися 12 липня оглядачі
це називають втішним призом оскільки
зробити формальне запрошення НАТО навряд
чи зможе
Мені важко уявити що НАТО збирається
запропонувати Україні членству Доки не
буде стабільною безпечною ситуацією
дехто каже А чому НАТО не може просто
надати гарантії тим частинам України які
під її контролем так само як це
поширювалося на західнонімеччину але не
на східну
головна відмінність полягає в тому що
зараз триває війна і якщо НАТО поширюють
свою п'яту статтю на ті частини країни
які контролюються Києвом Альянс
зіткнеться з перспективою вступу у війну
з Росією
якби бомба впала на Київ Одесу Львів чи
будь-де і НАТО не зміг би відреагувати
напрями напад на Київ це фактично
розвалило пальянс
Київ Тому НАТО не хочу опинитися в
такому становищі
тим не менше експерти і дипломати
продовжують тиснути на західні столиці з
вимогою підтримати запрошення України в
НАТО вже нині щоб запустити незворотний
процес який врешті-решт призведе до
вступу України в альянс і покладе край
амбіціїм Росії відновити імперію
оглядачі стверджують що це історичний
крок і кращого шансу ніж на саміт у
Вільнюсі для цього не буде водночас
більшість експертів схиляється до того
що результатом саме то Вільнюсі стане
проміжне рішення а формальний запрошення
України до Альянсу може відбутися вже на
наступному ювілейному 75-му саміті НАТО
у Вашингтоні